Let's see who else we can talk to here. How
about. Oh, I don't know. There's some very
interesting folks here. Why don't
we go to Cooper from South Carolina.
Hello, David. It's my first time calling, so I
have a couple of concerns about Medicare for all.
OK, so with the current system, I want to go to
a doctor appointment with a specialist doctor,
and it's going to take me like six months
to get seeing some on the waiting list.
OK, this is a real scenario. You're currently on
a waiting list. That's a six month waiting list.
Yeah. And what specialty is that? Dermatology?
No, it's actually a neurologist having some like
a nerve issues. So my fear is in a system that's
Medicare for all, perhaps the wait times would
be much longer. And I'm concerned that, like,
for example, the wait list was like a year,
a year and a half like that would make the care a
lot less valuable. Yeah. So I was wondering, like,
what's what do you think about that?
Yeah, I actually just did a video about
this a week and a half ago called Won't what
was it. Something like Won't Medicare for
all. I mean everybody is going to try to get
health care and gum up the system. So there's
a couple of different things. First of all, as
you are pointing out, we already have wait lists
and sometimes people have to wait for things. And
so one aspect of this is when you change a system,
some people still have to wait. It's sometimes
different people than the ones that are waiting
now. And ideally, wait would be commensurate
with inversely related to the degree of urgency
for the visit. That's that's number one.
Number two, you also, over the long term,
would be likely to reduce the need for
specialist visits by treating a lot of
things early. A lot of people now forgo going
to a primary care doctor at all because they
either don't have insurance or don't want to
pay their copay or whatever the case may be.
So something that could be dealt with without
a specialist early becomes something that then
you have to go to a specialist for. And so I
think that it's not these are complex issues.
There's no question. And there's examples of
when you expand access, you do increase the
demand at emergency rooms and it increases wait
times. And there are examples of that. I'm not
denying that. And these are complex issues.
But generally speaking, generally speaking,
it's much more nuanced than simply. Well,
if a lot more people have health care,
the waiting list that every specialist will go up.
Mm hmm. Yeah, I was thinking maybe at least for
like a like you were saying, like the primary
doctors, maybe you could have a Medicare for
all system for that, but then also have like a
public option for like more the specialty doctors,
just way like if you actually need to get
seen for something, you might be able to.
Yeah, I've never heard of Medicare for all plus
public option. I've heard of Medicare for all,
plus private insurance for those who prefer
it. I think in most systems, Medicare for all
makes the public option not necessary. But that's
something that would be interesting to look at.
OK, thank you.
All right, thank you so much,
I appreciate it. Very interesting questions.
That's going to do it for us for today.
But we will take calls again now in the
Biden era. Thanks to everybody who joined
me. We will take a quick break and be
back with much more right after this.